Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner. So this is episode two of my video blog through my journey of cancer to me and
encouragement to all my patients with cancer
Crazy, huh? Well, hopefully not very strange very
I told you in the first episode that I am
First of that doesn't like to share their old issues, but
Here we go again. I'm gonna get good at this at some point. All right, so I want to share with you this real brave
These they're all gonna be really these episodes are gonna be really short. So they're completely unscripted
Obviously if you watch the first one, you'll notice that and I gonna share you some things that I found best
I've been walking this walk for quite some time. So I'm gonna catch up with a bunch of episodes here in the next week here
So and then I'll probably do what every week or so
But there'll be a few that come kind of jump together here things that I found best that I felt helped me the best now
caveat here red flag just because it worked for me. It doesn't mean it's gonna work for you
Just because something didn't work for me. It doesn't mean it's not gonna work for you
So keep in mind that I also made a comment that I regret what I the last
The first episode I did is I said that the statistics that were so poor and by
Type of cancer. I said those people had done chemo and I'm not doing it was not intending to be after I listen to that again
That that people that do chemo do poorly. It's just my specific cancer
All the statistics and all the papers that I read about that it does not respond to chemotherapy
so
All the statistics that are so poor with my cancer
Which are all the statistics out there are with those people that did chemotherapy and that's
What I meant by I am not going to
necessarily be falling into that same statistic because I'm not falling into the same treatment pattern
So it's just goes back to
Okay, you want to know the definition of insanity keep doing the same thing and expect a different outcome
Well, I'm not doing the same thing as all the people that they did their studies on and what the statistics were based upon
So I have a lot more confidence
Right from there, but my confidence doesn't lie in all these wonderful things. I'm doing it
I'm not doing what those statistics were based on
My confidence lies in Jesus Christ. So I'm asking him for wisdom throughout this whole journey
And I'm going to tell you some of the things that I've found to be good and I will continue to share those things with you
So the FMD the fasting mimicking diet I felt was one of the best things for me now
I'm going to be totally upfront and honest. I hate doing it. I
Obviously like to eat. I'm sorry
It's just a confession. Okay, you only have to take one glance at me
There's a reason why I use this picture right here because
You know, I'm not the skittiest person in the world and I could stand to lose another 25 pounds
So I'm going to be doing another FMD very soon, but I need my wife here to help me because I'm
too weak-willed
So I've done several so far and I need to do another one, but that seemed to help me feel the best is the FMD
There's times with in my journey that my pain just starts to ramp up and ramp up
And then if I just go out of fast even a one-day fast, it really really helps me
So that's one of the things even if I don't do a full five-day FMD
Just do it a one-day fast, a 24-hour fast will help me
Usually it's a way like 20 hours, but that seems to really help
My diet is such that I test it out as
Needy to stay away from meat
So I have for the last year
Eat very very little meat, you know, I cheated on occasions where
They had a little chicken or something like that or a little bite of something
Nobody else in my family is
vegan or vegetarian so
You know, we have all our grandkids over and my family's over
We're still cooking meat for them. You know, it's not really a big temptation for me
That's something really easy for me to stay away from what's very hard for me to stay away from is sugar
Because I'm a sugar holic ever since I could remember since I was a kid my dad used to be in a restaurant
I did would give us packs of sugar here eat this and open it up and put it on a spoon for us. It was delightful
So that's the hardest thing for me to stay away from this sugar
So that's the struggle with the diet that I've had
Fasted is best for me. I usually need some support or I used to usually need to feel really lousy and that I get
You know excited about doing it fast, but usually you know, but I have a fair
I think I have a fairly high paid tolerance so that I just could ignore it and I tend to be a person that ignores my symptoms and
So that's not always that good. So
I
Need to think about them sometimes just to motivate myself to stay on pace and
Then the biggest thing that helps me is to be thinking about future play as a think about
What God has for me in this and I hope that these little
Episodes that I'm going to do and keeping in mind the purpose in this is bigger than me
That this will continue to motivate me to continue to move forward
I you know, I'm not superhuman in my emotions either
When I first discovered this I went through some
Valleys I still go through some valleys and I think if you don't go through valleys
There's something wrong with you. So valleys are good
Hills are nice, but
We're promised that whether we're in a hill or a valley this to shall pass and
That's part of the road that we walk
Whether you have serious diagnosis or not. I really
I am just so so thankful for my diagnosis. It just reminds me that
Your life is not forever here on earth and you can talk about eternity
You can talk about not living in the temporal and to keep your eyes on heaven and that we're supposed to be living
For our heavenly Father, but many times if we don't have
Something serious reminding us of those facts
It's all talking. It's not reality. It's becoming more of a reality for me, and I'm thankful for that
And then I'm going to be sharing some of the nutrients that I've been taking. I'm not going to get details on this because I'm trying to keep these short
But I found some that I feel like are working better for me
Then what I
I'm still on some of the first things I tested out with
One of the things that I tested out with is the black sand blood route. That's a capsule
And I still take that
The modified citrus pectin I still take that
And I still take mushrooms, but I don't take mushrooms every day
I didn't test out on the mushrooms, but I wanted to take them anyhow
Because they have polysaccharides that are so good to boost your immune system
So I still take mushrooms. I still take chaga
Probably every day. I'm taking chaga
But when I say mushrooms I'm talking about our powdered mushroom mix and I do greens almost every day
So and I use about three at least three scoops of greens every day
So I'm trying to
I don't juice. I just don't have time to juice
And so those are the kind of things I want to tell you
But there's some cool on the next episode there's a neat new
A supplement that I just started taking a couple weeks ago
It's a brand new supplement that we just got a couple weeks ago
And I talked to I spoke to the
the older the company who
The company has a patent on how they deliver it and how they how they perfected it
And they're going to share a whole episode on that
So this is episode two
We'll walk this walk with me and I walk this walk with you
Then we're going to help each other
All right, thanks. We will see you very soon